what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals the Judgment Day event
and this story here's the thing this
first issue pops off I mean it's just
like boom it just it hits hard what this
initially does here is it picks up with
a kind of discussion between Tony Stark
and Cersei of the eternals now one of
the things to know is that for a lot of
new comic book readers this is cool if
you are an older comic book reader this
is a throwback to like the 80s and 90s
right this is a throwback to the days
when like Cersei and the eternals were
far more involved with human Affairs
than we've seen recently specifically
Cersei she's been very very important
when it came to just the overall history
of the Avengers the X-Men all that kind
of stuff there's a lot of stuff there
and so it's kind of cool to see because
it takes me on a bit of a Nostalgia trip
from way back in the day but the thing
about this is that there's kind of a
conversation that's going on between the
two now one of the things to know is
that Cersei while her and Tony Stark
have of course been together physically
a variety of times and so on she never
really took them all that seriously and
that's because despite all of his wanted
intelligence and all that kind of stuff
Tony Stark never really took himself all
that seriously right he's a jokester
he's a Playboy right he's the guy he's
got it where it counts but he just kind
of passes himself off and puts himself
off as a guy that never takes anything
seriously so nobody ever really takes
him seriously that's one of the reasons
why the Civil War Story was so important
is because it was one of the very few
stories that you see that you've seen
over the course of Marvel's publication
history that focus on Iron Man outside
of like demon in a bottle or armor Wars
or something like that that showed a
very serious side of Tony Stark which
was really really cool but the thing
about this is that as they're having
this conversation there is a bit of a
discussion about how effectively the
eternals are now aware of the fact that
the X-Men have the power of Resurrection
now this was actually brought to the
eternals by way of someone named the
Jack of knives Jack of knives is an
eternal basically Jack is one of the
Eternal crime Lords and that's one of
the things that we'll talk about as we
go through this video is how the
eternals roster and the overall system
is kind of expanded really under the
writing of Kieran Gillen of course
largely being done by most likely as a
result of the MCU but that when that
information was brought to the eternals
the question is well what do we do with
this now and initially the eternals were
like who cares it doesn't really matter
that was until the concept of excess
deviation was brought in which is that
mutants are basically an offshoot of the
deviants that's somewhere along the line
a deviant Gene entered the human genome
like me through procreation and that all
mutants that exist now are basically a
result of humans possessing a deviant
Gene that's what the X Gene is now I
have ever since this was introduced we
did a video on geek culture explained
where it's like that's Marvel the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is in for mutants in
the Marvels in the MCU that's how
they're going to introduce they're going
to say the mutants are basically just an
offshoot of the deviants done right
that's why this is being done there's no
other reason to alter the entire history
and the origin of mutants outside of
that there's really no reason to do that
so the fact that they're doing it here
that's what really changes things that's
why it matters is because it's going to
become an MCU thing but in the midst of
this conversation suddenly you end up
having uh basically Cersei who's taken
by the uh taken by like Echo and Thor
and Captain Marvel basically like
attacked and whisked Away now the reason
why this is done why she's overpowered
is because Cersei if you're gonna take
her out you've got to be quick because
Cersei is a matter manipulator she's not
Universe wide she can't alter reality on
a universal scale but she can't alter
the structure of people she's facing off
against knock them unconscious any
number of things so if they attacked her
and the battle went on for more than
like a minute Cersei would basically get
the upper hand with a quickness that's
how powerful she is right somebody who's
able to overcome basically almost
anybody up to a particular limit most
Earthbound people and so that basically
allows the Avengers to take Cersei away
and so what this does is it switches
over to the X-Men at the tree house in
New York now remember for those of you
guys who are catching up with us the
tree house is basically the X-Men's
field base in the city of New York they
do exist in krakowa but the tree house
is kind of like a a field base right
it's where they can operate out of
specifically the main X-Men team Cyclops
Jean Gray different things like that now
what's kind of funny here and this is
something that has not been explicitly
addressed addressed yet at the time that
this comic was launched is that Cyclops
is basically in his normal Garb he's not
Captain krakowa so we're still fleshing
out exactly how that works in relation
to the greater landscape because
remember cyclops's death was public
people aren't supposed to know he's
still alive but one of the things that
gets talked about here is the fact that
the the story of Ben yurik that we had
covered previously which was him
basically revealing to the world that
the the mutant population has the
ability to resurrect themselves that
this has become known and not everybody
has reacted to it in a positive way some
people have reacted to this in a
predictable way which is that oh my God
the mutants had the ability to come back
to life well now they're more of a
threat than they ever were whereas other
people are reacting to it with anger
right like a woman's daughter is still
dead how come the X-Men get to come back
and her daughter doesn't the reality
here though is that Cyclops goes as far
as to say that the five can only really
bring back certain people specifically
those whose Minds have been backed up by
cerebra that's one of the caveats that
was established during Hickman's run
that if they brought back This Woman's
dead daughter she would would just be a
body with no memory of who she was
before literally she'd be just kind of
teaching her everything new so it'd be
her daughter who had returned but her
daughter wouldn't know who she was again
it's one of those things where Cyclops
isn't saying that the five can't bring
them back literally it's the five can't
bring them back as they know them which
is what they want they want the you know
that woman wants her daughter to come
back as she knew her daughter that kind
of a thing and so what ends up going on
here is you basically have a kind of
meeting between Nightcrawler and Destiny
and Mystique now remember what's been
going on since the return of Destiny is
Marvel's largely been building on her
ability to see the future now the way
that Marvel plays this and it's one of
the coolest things about it Destiny has
a wide and varying way in which her
ability to predict the future works the
most popular version and the one that
there was an entire story arc based
around was called Destiny's Diaries
basically these instances where she had
written down how things could play out
in the future and it was people's desire
to find those Diaries so they could
basically they could ensure that things
unfolded in the way they wanted to or
stop particular things from happening
and so what this does is it kind of
segues into the modern era which is if
something's going to happen in 10
minutes Destiny knows right off the bat
if something's going to happen in a day
or in a week or a month she can predict
it pretty accurately but if we're
talking about something in 50 years it
may or may not come to fruition because
a lot of things can happen in the span
of 50 years that can prevent that from
happening specifically what Destiny does
here is she says the eternals are coming
right the eternals are going to try to
kill us off this war is right around the
corner it's like right there and I can
see it coming and so in response to that
Nightcrawler basically travels to arako
right travels to Mars and then
essentially tells storm and and Magneto
and all those guys we have to assemble
the quiet Council we've got to assemble
the great circle or great the great Ring
in a Rocco basically their governing
body we have to make sure people know
the eternals are coming for us all the
thing about this is that Destiny does
not specifically know why the eternals
are going to do it she simply just knows
that they are right that she's predicted
that they are going to go to war with
the mutants and if the mutants are not
prepared they're all going to die now
funny thing about this is that it's kind
of approached in different ways storm
herself is like okay we have to approach
this from more of a political standpoint
how do we deal with this on a political
perspective Magneto's host stance is we
will take like we'll confront this Force
when it comes head on and he even goes
so far as to say that like the eternals
are the old gods right they were created
by the celestials these beings that were
supposed to keep the world safe and all
that kind of stuff we've moved Beyond
them we don't need the protection of the
eternals we have our own cure for for
death right we've solved the equation of
Resurrection we are more powerful than
they are and we're larger in number than
they are they're simply launching this
attack against us because much like the
humans they're afraid of their own
mortality we represent the next stage of
not really just Evolution but the next
stage of moving beyond them right if
they are our parents we are the children
ready to step out into the world and he
even goes as far as to say we are the
world's new Gods now and so that's kind
of the funny thing because at that point
you transitioned to Avengers Mountain
which is well at least is a place deep
inside the mountain where essentially no
tele empathic abilities will work so no
one can read the mind of Iron Man and
Cersei I mean she can read his mind I
guess but she can't telepathically call
for help literally it's one of those
things where it's like no one can hear
you scream there's no one you can call
for so you better start answering my
questions and again she just doesn't
really take him seriously you know she's
she's literally mocking him you know
he's like if you were in my shoes what
would you do and that kind of a thing
and she's like I would never be in your
shoes because you know you're you're you
know they don't look good right they
wouldn't look good on me that's when the
conversation gets serious where he's
like I'm not joking here I'm not [ __ ]
around I'm not goofing off right like I
am serious here I am 100 serious right
like I totally get that you were doing
your thing that like you as eternals you
have your own Society you're not really
a family you have your own campaigns and
what have you and you do your stuff and
that's fine right it's always been that
way you do your thing we do our thing
you don't show up for every Avengers
crisis event and we don't show up for
every eternals event but it becomes an
Avengers problem when we find out that
Thanos exists on Earth that he's here
and he's running the eternals right now
at the moment Thanos has been defeated
but that entire story arc right where
Thanos was on Earth and running the
eternals the eternals Never Told The
Avengers and the response of Iron Man is
this is a problem not only that Earth
was minutes away from destruction and at
no point did you tell us what was going
on that's when it becomes a problem
right so these are kind of two different
events happening at the same time and so
ultimately the response of Cersei is I
regret that and Iron Man's like that's
the problem Cersei you regret it but
you're not sorry about it there's no
apology here right you don't even say it
was a mistake your regret was not the
fact that you didn't tell us your regret
was that we found out that's the issue
that you have and that's why this is a
problem and so ultimately because of how
this interrogation is going in the end
Captain America shows up here now this
is a great moment because what it does
is it highlights how Captain America is
viewed by everybody right he literally
shows up and he's just like this method
of interrogation isn't working Tony
Stark and here's the thing Cersei was an
Avenger at one point we have to show her
some level of trust and and he tells her
the eternals are going to war with the
X-Men tell us what you know and Cersei
again plays the same card she did with
Iron Man where she's like well I mean I
know that war is significantly more
likely now that you've strapped me to
this uncomfortable and unfashionable
chair and Captain America just looks at
her and that's when she realizes okay
this is serious that's the nature of
Steve Rogers and it's a very easy thing
to overlook it's one of those things you
look at Captain America and it's like I
mean it's cool he can run fast and punch
hard rahu right he'd make a great
Olympian yeah you know the USA champion
in whatever competition he happens to be
in but the truth about this is because
of the things that Captain America's
done over his time as a superhero and
because of his standing among just
anybody on Earth human mutant Eternal
otherwise everybody respects him and
they know that when Captain America gets
serious when he stops joking that's when
things are a problem and that's why
Cersei stops she drops the act and she's
like you're serious a war an actual War
like like and so she's like what do you
know right like you have to know
something you wouldn't just kidnap me
bring me here and then tell me a war is
coming without having something to
verify that's the case and that's when
Iron Man's like okay so since everything
popped off with Thanos we learned about
all that stuff we've basically been
monitoring all Eternal activity and what
we found is that there was basically
Celestial energy that spiked and then
ended like almost immediately and the
response Associates but that's not
that's not weird like cosmic energy like
literally your Fantastic Four have
cosmic energy that's not uncommon and
his response is these are like a series
of low-level Rumblings that are
happening around the world something's
warming up something in the earth is
coming and because of the fact that you
as eternals have Celestial energy right
you're powered by cosmic energy and
you've been here for like a million
years who else is it gonna be right and
so it's like what are you doing what do
you have going on and the response of
Cersei is here's the thing you need to
understand we as eternals we're a
society we're not a family right we
don't owe anything to each other we use
the terms of familiar relations mother
father brother sister but we use that as
a stand-in for teammate right we we use
it in that capacity we consider
ourselves I guess a family to a degree
because there is a finite number of us
there will never be any more eternals
they're not being created anymore we
cannot die we'll always come back but we
can leave at any point in time and some
of us have some of us have abandoned the
eternals and we've taken up residence
with the deviance so here's the thing
you need to understand I'm not the
Eternal that you have to worry about
here and so what you do is you switch
over to Olympia the capital of the
Eternal City and you have druick who is
the Prime Eternal he's the one running
the show addressing basically what will
become the unimod and essentially saying
here's the problem we as eternals were
created for the purpose of one keeping
deviant the Deviant population in check
and two correcting excess deviation
which is a time where the Deviant Gene
becomes corrupted right like when
deviants experience a mutation of their
own essentially but unlike the human
population that experiences a mutation
and they develop a healing factor or
they become Charles Xavier who can read
minds when a traditional deviant
undergoes excess deviation they turn
into some grotesque monster and actually
start killing other deviants we
eliminate them and he's like but here's
the problem somewhere along the line the
Deviant Gene entered the human gene pool
and now mutants are excess deviation our
job to follow our Charter the task
assigned to us by the celestials if we
are going to correct I.E eliminate
excess deviation we have to kill the
mutants so I am asking the unimind to to
vote on this I'm asking the unit to
support this and the unimind agrees and
so what this does is it leads to druick
visiting uranos in the exclusion now
orenos is one of the original eternals
when the eternals were initially created
right which is to say like they were
initially formed by the celestials
Uranus was one of the first and he is
one of the most powerful of the eternals
now initially it was believed that he
was dead and in fact he was kind of
killed to a degree instead of him being
resurrected he was kind of sort of a
patchwork clone but the real reality is
again using the kind of familiar
relations he is by all standards the
measurement the grandfather of Thanos
right like literally that's who he is
he's that powerful he's on that level of
scale and it's one of these cool things
where drewick says okay if we are going
to launch an attack against the mutant
population you're you are arguably the
most powerful of us so we are going to
give you a task he says you have an hour
one hour the machine has coded you to
return here instantly right because
remember the whole idea behind iranos is
the and the reason why he's locked up is
that during the early days when the
eternals were initially created Uranus
thought that the best way for the
eternals to maintain their role was to
literally eliminate all humans and all
all deviants and then just conquer the
world and then spread out from there
that led to a civil war among the
eternals and he was effectively killed
for lack of a better word but then
cloned and brought back so he's not a
truly resurrected Eternal and so that's
why he's a prisoner here because the
ongoing fear among the eternals is that
if he is released he would incite
another Civil War among the eternals or
perhaps just simply try to kill them all
and then refuse to resurrect them
because he who is the Prime Eternal is
the one that controls the machine and he
who controls the machine decides who
gets resurrected and so what what Uranus
says in one of the most amazing
statements ever he says my own people
have forgotten me these mutants made
Mars habitable in a day but to destroy
is always easier a human takes nine
months to make another breathe a human
can crush a windpipe in seconds you will
see what Uranus the undying can do with
an hour and so he basically goes forward
on his mission and will find out what
that is what this does is it switches
over to druig as part of the Damocles
Foundation now the Damocles Foundation
was founded way back in the day its
Mission has basically changed now the
Druid is the head he's like the prime
Eternal but initially the basis behind
the Damocles Foundation is that it was a
coming together of humans and deviants
and eternals who believed that this kind
of constant war that was going on
between humans or between the eternal
events and whatnot would lead to the
ruin of all and so their goal was to
actually find some kind of a peaceful
resolution to this sort of Warring
nature of their differing societies and
then try to see that come to fruition
sometimes this works in Honda hasn't
they've usually operated behind the
scenes but they've never really seen
their goal come to fruition but what
ends up happening here is you actually
have druick who's meeting with Maura
McTaggart and really she's allying with
him with the idea of finding a way to
eliminate the entirety of the mutant
population because remember more
McTaggart was the one who started kokoa
in the first place and unbeknownst to
Xavier and Magneto when they allied with
her to create kruhoa to create this
mutant Utopia that what more McTaggart
actually wanted to do was slowly
eliminate the mutant Gene so there would
be no mutants because in every life that
she lived right her power was to
basically die and then to come back to
life in essentially a new reality right
kind of a restarting of the universe so
to speak that in every single future
that she saw mutants were always killed
mutants were always destroyed by the
forces that they were going against
right humans host humans you know
whatever the case happened to be so her
idea was to essentially slowly phase out
the X Gene remove it entirely and save
the lives of mutants by getting rid of
mutants completely and so when that was
brought to fruition she was stripped of
her powers using the gun of Forge right
which basically nullifies abilities and
she was kicked out of krakowa and so as
a result of this she kind of Harbors
this Vendetta where one she has a kind
of personal Grudge to want a secret KOA
fail but two she steadfast in her
Mission and so as a result of this what
ends up happening is there a kind of
agreement that struck where it's like I
will do what I can to work with you
because right now uh more mctaggard is
allied with orcas right for those of you
guys who aren't following the X-Men
comic orcas is just this organization
that exists out there that is a
combination of of like Hydra and
advanced idea mechanics and like former
Shield agents and things like that who
are all working to bring down the X-Men
and so her outline with the eternals
basically provides the eternals with the
resources of orcas because for the
moment their goals are aligned and so
where you what you end up having is
Druid revealing that what the eternals
are doing is launching a three-pronged
attack which is genius in terms of how
this unfolds and that's what happens
when you face off against the eternals
they've been around for a million years
they've watched Wars they've fought Wars
they've observed them they've seen how
things go on right they see how how to
win in a conflict the military strategy
of Captain America is nothing in
comparison to the strategy of the
eternals because they've just been
around for so long and so what ends up
happening is the the first prong of this
attack is the unit mind of the eternals
at least those who are still under the
controller at least under the leadership
of uh of Druid the prime Eternal that
unimind launches a telepathic attack
against the against the quiet Council
and those telepaths who exist on krakowa
right Charles Xavier Jean Gray those
guys right that kind of unified front
with that telepathic attack happening
right Exodus and all those guys with
that telepathic attack happening what it
does is it keeps them distracted it
keeps them focused on that attack on
that conflict while that conflict is
happening basically foot soldiers are
sent in right and these foot soldiers
offer another distraction for The Other
Guys Wolverine and Laura Kinney and
cyclops and magic and all those guys
right and because of the power of these
forces everybody literally runs to
krakowa right like all the X-Men and
everybody they bail out on a Rocco they
run to krakowa and they fight the battle
there now while that's going on two
other things go on so I guess it's more
of a four-pronged attack two other
things happen the next phase of the
attack is for druig to actually send in
Jack of knives when Drew extends Jack of
knives in because Jack of knives is an
eternal that can render themselves
invisible that what it does is it allows
Jack to get in there and start killing
the five right remember the five are the
ones who resurrect mutants and so this
is this this is just ridiculously
awesome by targeting the five it
destroys the ability for mutants to be
resurrected or at least that seems to be
the case now in order for that to happen
in order for Resurrection to be ended
entirely all of the mutants have to like
all members of the five have to be
killed the problem is that Wolverine
catches up up to Jack of knives now
under normal circumstances Jack of
knives would be undetectable to
Wolverine Jacob knives can Mash their
scent to the point that Wolverine can't
pick it up but what wolverine does pick
up is the blood on the dagger that Jack
of knives was using which is a genius
Strat is it just a genius piece of
writing here and so basically it allows
Wolverine to essentially stop Jack of
knives from killing all the members of
the five and so this is when you get to
the final phase of the attack as is
outlined by Druid right the Jack of
knives did technically fail and were
more mctaggard is like you had your one
chance to destroy the ability for
mutants to resurrect themselves the
response of Druid is patience right you
are looking at things in the short term
because you haven't lived as long as I
have it's all about patience right at
the very least we will have eroded their
numbers and when the questions asked by
more mctagirl what about all the mutants
the the one million mutants that exist
on a Rocco right what about all of them
the response of Druid is they're not our
concern because what you end up finding
out is that the task of Uranus was to go
to Morocco to go to Mars and kill every
single mutant there and he's seemingly
done exactly that cable Magneto all
those guys storm he eradicated them all
that's the power of Uranus that's how
powerful that guy is he killed them all
seemingly on his own and so he's
immediately teleported back as soon as
that hour is over druig teleports back
to uh to the capital city right to the
exclusion Zone on the in the capital
city of the eternals and that's when
he's told by Uranus you're gonna need me
again right you have to let me out
you're gonna need me and the response to
Druid is if that time comes then we will
let you out but until then that's not
going to happen and so in the face of
all of this right when this attack
launched on the X-Men the entirety of
the mutant population Uncle Kawa just in
disorganized disarray right the mutants
on a Rocco those individuals who can be
resurrected have been resurrected right
basically the mutants just kind of left
in a state of panic and Chaos having no
real idea on what's going on the
response of druig is to actually tap
into the the world's electronic systems
and broadcast live simultaneously to
every human around the world and what he
says is this he says people of Earth I
am Druid of the eternals I am speaking
to you via your extremely impressive
high-tech devices and that's when like
Captain America realizes everybody's
getting this message even the Avengers
are watching this message Andrew says I
could use telepathy but we consider that
intrusive and crass it's a Nouveau
Immortal move and yes I'm talking about
these mutants they're a threat to you
all they have overstepped their natural
bounds and clearly aim for a Dominion
that stretches across worlds and
Eternity we apologize that we've let
them go so far but rest assured we serve
you as we have for a million years and
humanity is championing this humanity is
celebrating this right the basically the
Eternal stepping up and saying we will
eliminate the mutant threat for you but
drewig says however we must ask you to
not be afraid of the Towering death
machines that have emerged off the
Western Seaboard of the United States
the they are not towering death machines
they are the hex and they are eternals
yes we're not all human-sized but rest
assured whether large or small we are
your protectors that said we would
advise anyone in any coastal regions to
head Inland as swiftly as they can it's
possible this may get messy now this is
one of the things that's been going on
with the eternals comics those guys who
haven't really been watching our videos
on it the entire basis behind Kieran
gillen's realm with the eternals is to
expand them drastically it's an entire
society and it's way more than the
eternals that we were initially
introduced to in Marvel Comics there's
so much more to them than that they come
in all shapes and sizes all forms it's
wild how this is going down it's really
really cool and so in response to all of
this Captain America assembles The
Avengers and so what happens is that
while the Avengers are being assembled
and trying to find some way to respond
to what the eternals are doing Iron Man
picks up on on basically an intrusion
alarm and when it gets there he
basically finds ajack and he finds
Makari now the funny thing about this is
that they're basically getting in the
same way that like they had gotten him
before which Iron Man kind of takes is a
little bit of an insult but they've also
got Sinister in taupe which explains why
Sinister had basically vanished from the
X-Men's quiet Council where it is that
he's been all this time he's being held
captive by the eternals and the idea
here the goal of the eternals at least
those who have broken away from Druid
who don't really operate under the
Eternal main society right so think of
them as like the uh like the American
separatists that broke away from England
and like founded what became the United
States that's kind of what the eternals
are to a degree but the thing about this
is their job is to say okay look this is
a holy war right like what what drewig
is doing is He is building what his he's
building his actions based on the the
you know Godly decree right the holy
decree of the celestials which is we as
eternals correct excess deviation he's
using that as a reason to wipe out the
X-Men so if it is Gods who established
this then it is God who can correct this
we need the celestials to make this
happen and we need a God as a Celestial
that can do this for us right that can
establish a new law and when the
question is asked by Iron Man okay I
mean this is interesting but where the
hell are you going to make a God in a
few hours the response of macarian ajac
is look around you man we're literally
inside of a dead Celestial it can't be
that impossible to resurrection and the
reality is that it's not remember back
in back in 2008 during Charles Knox run
which is the the at least one of the
eternals runs that we have so we'll
create a playlist for Judgment Day so it
all kind of comes together and makes
sense that the eternals do have an
afterlife they visit the fulcrum once
they basically quote unquote die right
the fulcrum being an aspect of the one
above all uh they do have like a kind of
afterlife you can recall a dead
Celestial you can bring them back now
whether or not that happens is something
that we'll see over the course of this
story but I gotta say man Judgment Day
hits with a bang so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you guys for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]